Gary do you mind explaining
what you do and what your focus is to
John
I know that I'm not sure if you both
have met no before so this is John
vervaki from U of T Gary I mean sorry
John this is Gary from Stanford Gary
Nolan
oh my my pleasure yeah my day job is
Immunology cancer Imaging algorithms for
interpreting bioinformatics things like
that uh We've spun out a number of
companies
um but you know for John and I think a
lot of people on the on the uh on the
YouTube who who know me my interest has
been in how to formalize research in
such exotic topics as uh as UAP right
how do you and I don't mean this in any
kind of a derogatory sense how do you
teach the lay public to ask questions
about science that doesn't presuppose a
conclusion that basically puts them in a
position of looking like you know being
made a fool of which is what you know
has been done for decades and across
many disciplines it's not just UAP so
it's about you know how to get people to
agree that the data is real and then
once the data is real real way you can
flip the tables on people and say okay
well I don't have to explain it it's not
my responsibility you can't just you
know turn down and critique everything I
I suggest it's the responsibility of any
good scientist to also suggest Solutions
uh so that's been you know that's been
one of my major ones and and then the
other is that more recently in speaking
with philosophers and I wish I saw the
people who were on just previously you
know what are the burdens of proof for
different kinds of observations
you know a burden of proof for a
so-called experiencer is different than
that of a uh of a scientist but both of
these people want to talk to each other
so coming up with with a linguistic path
that allows them to talk to each other
in a way that they're not talking past
each other I think is important
very interesting uh do you talk to them
about issues around bias and
self-deception yeah oh yeah I mean
especially the um
what's it called it's uh it's a French
it's a French term for uh the the folio
do right that basically there's a you
know feedback mechanism between two
people who reinforce their delusion if
you will
um and so yeah there's a there's a lot
of that I mean most of the work that
I've done with people who are let's say
uh orbiting the the government uh on
this issue
um are scientists who spent a lot of
time especially with the psychological
aspects of this actually verifying that
the people that were collecting data
from don't have some other kind of
mental health issue I mean the problem
is that many of these many people are
they actually are both they both have
kind of a mental health condition
because of the experience and because of
society's reaction to that yeah
um so there's a you know disentangling
that is is just as bad a um a problem as
anything else
yeah it's been related work on potential
overlaps between what you might call
foolishness which is an epistemic and
moral failure to address self-deceptions
like that and then
um and mental health issues that also
have that kind of uh biasing of
attention and salience dysregulation and
so there's a gray line where I would
expect you to find a large number of
people where it's hard to disentangle
those two yeah no I mean it's I mean we
use in some ways the same things that we
do for the clinical studies that we're
involved with with cancer researches we
do a lot of
what's called inclusion exclusion
criteria you have to make sure that
you're comparing Apples to Apples yes
um so that your statistics can be more
powerful because you're focusing on a
um on a more uniformed group I mean the
problem with uniformity of course is
that it misses all of the interesting
stuff in the middle
you know it's often stuff in the middle
that's that you can explain the edges
usually but the stuff in the middle is
where the fun stuff happens and it might
miss stuff that transfers right it
doesn't generalize or transfer
appropriately to the individual
differences that pick out a particular
pathological population either so you
get the you get the problem the other
way too that you may be missing other
than causal factors that way
you know for me I mean I think the
pilots were brought up a moment ago
people like Ryan Graves and others you
know that here you have experts who are
then let's say turned upon by I'll call
them pseudoskeptics uh and grouped with
you know the uh let's say the less
Savory characters uh in the UFO
Community or you know basically people
who do have you know issues or saw the
wrong thing and and so they're very
credible testimonies and observations
are basically brought down to earth if
you will by commentary that Associates
them with absolutely ridiculous you know
comparisons or comparators
so I mean that's that's part of the
problem but my you know my push has
always been uh you know always go after
the inevitable
right always aim for the inevitable the
things that you know must be true I mean
obviously that's going to be very
self-serving uh objective and that you
you know what you think is is inevitable
might not be what somebody else does but
I think if you can Define what's truly
inevitable and then focus on it and just
ignore the critics you know it's it's
three parts confidence
you know two parts ignorance that
actually is what drives progress
in these kinds of areas so
um you know that's always been my
Approach
people I remember you know people have
said Gary you're very confident I said
I'm not confident I just I just want to
do it
right and if you don't have a decision
of something a hypothesis you're trying
to
test
then there's you know then you just you
know you're just left in this kind of
wishy-washy area of never proving or
disproving something yeah
you know I've always uh I I like using
this analogy that one of my mentors from
grad school you know told me Lee
herzenberg and she was saying look
there's two kinds of questions there's a
Las Vegas question where the answer is
yes and no and if you waste you spend
six months on know what you're
interested you know that's a bad thing
obviously the Las Vegas outcome might be
great but sometimes there's a kind of a
Zen Twist of the question that you can
apply that makes any question
interesting no matter the answer and so
that's where I think it kind of flips
back to the UAP phenomenon is that the
answer is interesting no matter what
right whether it's We're Alone
how fascinating
or there is something how amazing uh you
know the question the real open question
is how close is the something is it here
or are we just is it just more hopeful
thinking
I'm curious John and and Gary what is
your earliest childhood memory
John if you don't mind
I was laying on the living room floor I
was three and something I'm wondering
what school was like
how old were you oh it's really three
and a half or so just before I was gonna
go to about it about eight months or so
before he's gonna go to school
and you were anxious about it like no no
not at all you're excited I was curious
I was I was wondering what my sisters my
older sisters did at school what school
was like that's my so I guess I was
destined from the beginning to be an
academic my first memories about what's
school like exactly yeah
and Gary
um I have like three or four from like I
mean
like before we came to his country when
I was one and a half on a ship actually
from Liverpool
and so I remember
being passed out the window at one point
in Liverpool to my father
uh who put me on the back of a motorbike
I remember being for the first time
actually put on a toilet I remember
seeing the toilet in front of me
um and I remember being on the ship left
alone by my mother because my father was
already in the United States so these
are all kind of frightening moments you
know I mean I I don't really remember
much Beyond those but those moments were
oh I remember being brought out to the
front of the ship and it was just sort
of this Misty thing so I must have been
before one and a half but they're just
like flashes no cognizance
right just kind of these flashes of
stuff that I can still see I don't think
then the the next memories came until I
was around three which were kind of
little stories
and Carlos and Dan and Andy sorry if I'm
monopolizing if you have any questions
for for Gary and John please
please ask it's a bit difficult because
we're doing this virtually and so
interjecting is always tough but please
I've got like a million questions
especially for someone like Gary I could
speak to on a daily basis
um but not to waste too much time and
Gary and Jordan director for both yeah
you both mentioned though mental health
in terms of the in the UFO topic and
it's a huge a huge area especially in
2022 going into 2023 and Beyond and I
just wonder how how do you navigate the
conversation
in terms of the UFO topic especially
when it goes into the political Arena
when you're hoping to have hearings in
the U.S Congress and further afield
without it coming across like it is a
massive mental health issue because
that's the way I think a lot the general
public or even if I have conversations
with people I work with the way they see
the topic is people are either crazy
or they've misidentified something
well I mean
you know you should see my email inbox
sometime with some of the you know the
longer the email the less usually
yeah
five-page you know diatribes and it's
like I don't even have
um you know I I tried very carefully I
mean look I'm not an MD and I'm
certainly not a psychiatrist
um but uh I think one of the good things
about the openness of the topic is
amongst the many emails I get are
actually emails from psychiatrists and
uh um Health mental health officials
um and uh you know they say hey how can
we help right what can we do to organize
uh and provide
um you know more than just a little
local groups sorry about the dog
um
and uh you know I think it's again
similar I mean I don't I don't have the
wherewithal within the right communities
but it's similar to what Ryan Graves has
been doing uh with the um American
Institute of
uh
quiet all right Aeronautics where he has
created a group of people who can talk
to the other Pilots uh about the
observations that they've had and give
them the kind of feedback that allows
them to not have a fear for their jobs
or fear for their sanity
um so I'm involved with a number of
others uh to actually set up um an
independent Institute uh that will
amongst several things among policy
papers and other things that we'll write
around the whole UAP project also to
have an arm around uh the social aspects
of things and so hopefully we'll be able
to announce that later this year we've
already got some of our first major
donations
I mean what's exciting to me is the
amount of interest that is here and the
amount of available resources is
extraordinary it's really just about
coordination and ignoring those stupid
articles in the Wall Street Journal and
Julian Barnes and all of that
Ridiculousness I mean just don't pay
those kinds of people any attention
because they're really
um I think their objective is to
demoralize those who are working in the
area and not so much as to spread
disinformation right I think
disinformation is one thing
that's been done but I think the attempt
to demoralize uh is more uh I think
dangerous
uh it's demoralizing those who want to
do it who want to invest who've already
made a decision that this is something
that should be worked upon
um sorry to interject but why is it you
think that they're interested in
demoralizing do you think that that's
their their conscious
aim or that's just an artist I think
it's both I mean I I know I don't want
to get all conspiratorial but I mean if
you're doing a psyop it's not just about
throwing litter into the conversation
it's about stopping your opponents from
even wanting to win
so Andy got a question and so John if
you recall the question
can you answer if not Andy can you
repeat
uh I don't know if John does but it just
generally has thinking around the UFO
topic and and mental health how you have
that open conversation similar to Gary I
get people asking me telling me their
experiences and they've had these like
Gary says five six seven pages worth of
emails to tell you an incredible story
as a one-off event or that's happened
throughout their life and they're
frustrated that those conversations
aren't being had in a more mainstream
way at the kind of higher levels well
they assume they aren't being had but
the worry is that if those are talked
about in terms of experiencers being on
kind of late night news chat shows
they're going to be laughed at they're
going to be mocked and ridiculed and I
just wonder how how those conversations
can make their way into the mainstream
in a serious way
I don't interact with uh UFO people at
all today too that hasn't come across I
don't know if that's just because of uh
the kind of work I do or the community
um so I don't I don't have too much to
say about this specific topic I can
speak to the general topic which I do a
lot of work on
which is
um refurbishing our note our notion of
rationality uh we have a far too narrow
and truncated notion that doesn't
actually serve
um most of uh
most of action of actual existence and
living
um
and
for example I think there's far too much
of a priority put on a certain kind of
inferential logical ability that
probably isn't as Central to uh
rationality as overcoming self-deception
is which often involves very different
kinds of strategies around detention
proper understanding of how memory Works
Etc which people can be well educated in
the difficulty comes you know in about
when
issues of irrationality and issues of
pathology are intertwined together
um
because it's very hard in that gray area
to
exclude the people that need to be
excluded because
you have to understand for large groups
of topological individuals allowing them
into this conversation is actually
detrimental
right it reinforces the pathology in
ways that will prevent them from seeking
the help they need
Etc so there are
um again I I'm not trying to uh take
sides or be conspiratorial there are
genuine Quantified cases or groups of
cases where you want to include people
through these conversations because it's
deleterious to them and then how do you
separate that from
uh people who may be saying things that
seem initially very odd or strange but
are ultimately uh rationally valuable
that is easy to State as a thing it's
very hard to do
um and the reason is they it's like I
say people don't fall cleanly and
exhaustively and exclusively into one of
these roots or another you'll have
people
right who might be saying things that
are strange but epistemically worthy of
Investigation one minute and the next
minute saying things that definitely
indicate there's a pathology at work and
then what do you do with those
individuals do you allow them to keep
speaking because of the epistemic value
of what they're saying but that's
detrimental to their Therapeutic Health
do you intervene therapeutically but
then that's at the epistemic cost of
silencing a voice that may be bringing
arguments or evidence to bear it's a
hard issue and it's not specific to this
issue you know it pertains to people who
claim to have talked to Angels what do
you do with people like that and I'm not
saying I'm not trying to reduce one to
the other I'm not doing that I'm just
trying to give you that this is a this
is a very generic problem and we're not
doing a lot to talk about that we have a
category sanity we have other category
rationality how many conversations in
depth have you heard where people are
trying to work out what's the
relationship between rationality and
Sanity
I haven't heard a lot of these
conversations but the conversations we
need to have and we need to have them
not just because of this issue but of
many issues where it's very difficult to
determine how we should be interacting
with individuals or groups of
individuals like I said Andy I can't
talk to the specific issue I I am
virtually ignorant about it uh but on
the on the what you might call the
psychological epistemic issue about
rationality and Sanity
that's something that I I think we need
to be talking a lot more about and it's
something that I do my work is directed
towards I hope that's at least helpful
no absolutely as in I think sometimes
it's nice to hear logic from people that
are thinking who aren't involved in the
UFO topic on the UFO topic to give you a
fresh perspective or at least kind of
word things in a different way so I
appreciate that from yourself and from
Gary cart I have to head off uh but this
has been great thank you Dan hi uh happy
holidays yes it's been months yes uh and
I'll I'll
need to go ahead too well Gary like I
want to thank you for coming on board
Gary Nolan is one of the names that you
think about first when you think about
hard Research into the UFO topic so
you're Paving the way for further
research and I appreciate that Gary and
I think I speak for several hundred
people who are watching I'm not even
sure it's 700 several hundred six
hundred eight hundred one thousand now
one thousand apparently
so thank you Gary for coming on happy
holidays man it's good to see you and
and shut up those dogs
take take control of those dogs I'm just
kidding around man we love it we love
them take care man
nice meeting you Gary
[Music]
I can't quite hear you he said he's
gonna go look up your work he switched
mics okay let me know what you think of
what you said was fascinating all right
bye-bye bye bye Andy bye bye Gary have a
great New Year bye guys now The Real
Party begins it's just us check these
guys out I'm just kidding denied
okay there we go there's the jockey
comes back
so what's up everybody uh hi John uh
good to meet you I I followed uh some of
your podcasts uh they were extremely
helpful because I was setting up uh sort
of a group of people here in in Spain
where I missed where we're trying to get
together different traditions of
Christianity atheism and different
spiritual traditions and I'm trying to
set up sort of uh I mean I don't know
what the right word in English is but
something
like reflection reflection groups and
some kind of uh ways of uh coming
together and just talking life and
talking so spirituality and I'm
wondering right I was wondering if you
have any insights on I I'm sure you have
a lot of experience but if you have any
insights on the phenomenon that a lot of
practices across different Traditions uh
kind of converge into similar sort of
meditation you know praise yeah
yeah yeah I mean I'm so I'm very much
about not by giving people a set recipe
of practices like do this do this do
this do this what I do instead is I I
look for sort of two things I look for
what I call Design principles what are
the best ways of like designing an
Ecology of practices what kind of
features do you want in it uh you want
important processing you want nested
opponent processing
um you want a proper pedagogical program
so things are introduced in the right
order of operations uh you want layering
so it can you have practices that appeal
to different kinds of knowing within the
psyche and coordinate between them so
those are design principles I look for
a processing nested upon a processing uh
pedagogical program and layering so you
want those definitely and then I look
for domains what are the domains that
are the ones that are going to bring
about
um
what spirituality I think of
spirituality as conforming to deeper
dimensions of reality in order to afford
the cultivation of wisdom where wisdom
is the
uh amelioration of foolishness and the
affordance of meaning and life for me
um so uh you look for domains uh there's
mindfulness domains obviously uh there
are movement domains there are nature
connection domains there are biological
uh domains
um I tend to argue and not uh and this
is sort of bridges between being a
domain and design principle but you want
your colleges of practice you can do on
your own or in a small group but then
you want a dialogical practice for
larger
group collective intelligence that
serves as sort of your your your you
know the next Buddha is the saying it
serves as your Sage to give people
guidance
um uh someone wants to know how do you
explain Buddhism to a Westerner John
how would I explain Buddhism to a
Westerner
um I would say avoid uh initially
Western versions of Buddhism that have
been cleaned up and make Buddhism look
other than it is
um uh I think Evan Thompson why I'm not
a Buddhist and even Bachelors after
Buddhism are very powerful critiques of
Western Buddhism uh Western Buddhism
claiming that Buddhism is more
scientific which is really a bad
argument because Western Buddhism has
basically removed a lot of the
non-scientific stuff from uh you know uh
uh Eastern Buddhism if I will put it
that way and therefore it made it look
more scientifically palatable
um I would explain Buddhism
um only after somebody has engaged in
practices for some time
uh and do the Eightfold Path uh and and
do it seriously do it as an Ecology of
practices you want to know what Buddhism
is go into the existing Ecology of
practices a full path is a perfect
example by the way what I mean by an
Ecology of practices it has a point of
processing there's a pedagogical program
it has layering everything is
dynamically self-organizing do that for
a while and then start reading about
Buddhism
if you go from the text first
it's it's like well I make this joke but
it's like reading the Kamasutra and
never making love you you won't get it
you won't understand it you're
fundamentally misinterpret it
um and like I say I'm very critical of
Western Buddhism because of the way it
misrepresents
um historical Buddhism and the way it
also tends to reduce why do you think
that is
why do I think that is because is it
just a few individuals who are
responsible for this in some movement or
is there some larger reason uh no I
think it's it's I I don't I don't think
they were Sinister I think they were
responding to very powerful cultural
imperatives right a market bottom line
idea right can we simplified get cut to
the chase what's it all about uh how can
I what's this what's the basic practice
how can I make this work as simply as
effectively as possible and you reduce
all of my let alone Buddhism you reduce
all the mindfulness to one thing seated
meditation which is ridiculous I mean
yeah compared to doing nothing seated
meditation is great but if you want to
transform something as Dynamic and
complex
as a self within a community of persons
within a culture now you've got to do
something way more powerful but it's
easy to Market
mindfulness for stress reduction so that
you will be a very contented corporate
drone
that's easy to Market and that's easy to
sell and that's easy to get people to
jump on board because you get immediate
effects
stress reduction will start working
within eight weeks it does that's what
it does transforming your character
bringing about the cultivation of wisdom
you really think you're going to do that
in eight weeks could you learn to play a
musical instrument well in eight weeks a
martial art in eight weeks come on it's
ridiculous to believe that
all right you just watched a clip from
an eight hour live stream Behemoth
Leviathan podcast from theories of
everything which is a channel where we
explore physics mathematics and
Consciousness what is the Theory of
Everything how do you merge Quantum
field Theory with General relativities
click here or in the description for the
full podcast where there are several
people make appearances all the way from
George Knapp to Jeremy Corbell to Gary
Nolan to Avi lope to John verakee to
Donald Hoffman to Michael Levin to Ian
mcgilchrist and 40 more all in one eight
hour long podcast links in the
description